mon petit ami et notre joli lit pour la
nuit c'est notre abri et il
pleut à verse comme vous le voyez à new
york aujourd'hui il y a un tas de
différents types d'itinérance que
j'ai vécu à chaque extrémité du
spectre chaque partie de l'itinérance
chaque  sans-abrisme
nous n'étions pas préparés du
tout c'est la dernière fois que je vais faire une
vidéo répondant à ce commentaire
j'avais un travail il avait un travail nous avons perdu
nos deux revenus à la fois et c'est là que nous avons
commencé à dormir dans les parcs
et j'étais comme  d'accord, nous devons quitter
la rue
[Musique]
Grande-Bretagne
tu nous as eu tu me fais totalement semblant
nous ne dormons certainement pas
dans un parc en ce moment avec toutes nos
affaires tout ce que je demande c'est de la compassion
et un peu  un peu de compréhension ou d'
amour traitez-moi simplement comme un être humain normal
c'est tout ce que nous voulons vraiment ne
nous frappez pas quand nous sommes déjà déprimés comme si
je dormais dans un [ __ ] de parc ici mec
il n'y a pas besoin d'être impoli avec moi sur la technologie
parle aussi
j'utilise mon tic tac  pour en quelque sorte
sensibiliser aux réalités de l'
itinérance et de la toxicomanie et de la
récupération comme la vraie récupération
derrière tout cela,
je veux humaniser les sans-abri que
nous avons dormi ici pendant environ deux nuits et
j'étais à moitié endormi allongé là
et ce gars il vient marcher  vers le bas et
j'avais été en quelque sorte en train de régler tout le monde en
sortant euh mais il lui a dit quelque
chose et j'ai immédiatement sauté et il
était comme whoa attendez êtes-vous un couple
et j'étais comme quoi que voulez-vous et
je juste il a juste continué à parler  et j'étais
comme que voulez-vous et finalement il est
juste parti comme si je pensais qu'il
allait monter et essayer d'attaquer Courtney
il a vu juste une fille assise ici pensait
qu'il pensait qu'elle était seule et a
vu une opportunité de l'
attaquer je  je pense que c'est ce qu'il
allait faire il avait l'air effrayé quand tu t'es
assis c'est pourquoi j'ai eu c'est comme ça que j'avais
si peur et je ne la laisserais pas dormir
dans la rue sans moi
juste à cause de trucs comme ça qui peuvent
arriver tous les jours yo  tu sais
[Musique]
je me souviens en fait de la première nuit où
vous êtes venus comme si vous étiez en désordre
cette nuit-là ouais
vous pleuriez
et puis comme le lendemain courtney était
comme si je voulais me marier
c'est comme quoi tu veux dire  vous devez
obtenir un partenariat domestique pour entrer dans
quelques refuges et nous ne nous quittions pas
comme si nous ne voulions pas nous quitter,
elle va seule dans un refuge, c'est
ce que nous devions faire
pour sortir de la rue  donc nous venons de le faire
euh mais
ouais il y a des années, je veux dire quand nous nous sommes rencontrés pour la première fois,
nous parlions de nous marier
comme si ce n'était même pas un gros problème, nous
étions comme ouais d'accord faisons-le c'était
drôle parce que comme tout le monde dans le
palais de justice  était là pour se marier et
les filles portaient toutes vous savez comme de
belles robes qu'ils ont embauché des
photographes et des choses et nous étions
là avec nos sacs de la rue
j'étais comme un pyjama ouais la main sur un
pantalon de survêtement nous n'avions pas pris de douche depuis
cinq jours parce que  nous étions encore  vivre
dans la rue et nous étions comme d'accord,
nous sommes ici pour nous marier d'
accord,
nous nous sommes levés très vite
[Musique]
alors mise à jour on nous a refusé un
logement permanent on nous a de nouveau refusé un
logement permanent je me suis réveillé
à notre porte et  si vous ne savez pas
ce que c'est, ce sont les papiers qui nous
ont été refusés pour le logement
pour la troisième ou la quatrième fois à ce
stade, donc pas vraiment surpris parce que nous
n'avions pas les papiers dont nous avions besoin
pour cela, j'ai toujours besoin d'un
carte de sécurité sociale et un certificat de naissance
et comme nous avons besoin d'une preuve de chaque
résidence dans laquelle nous avons séjourné au cours de l'
année écoulée, ils doivent essentiellement confirmer
ou obtenir la preuve que nous étions
sans abri dans la rue, comme où nous dormions et
où nous mangions,
nous avons juste  veulent obtenir un logement permanent afin que
nous puissions être stables et trouver des emplois et nous
remettre sur pied et sortir du
système et ils rendent cela presque
impossible à ce stade
[Musique]
personne ne s'arrête jamais pour penser à ce qui s'est passé
dans la vie de quelqu'un pour  mener  eux à ce
point où c'est la seule option qu'ils
ont
[Musique]
j'étais un enfant intelligent je lisais avant d'
être à la maternelle et j'étais premier de ma
classe j'ai un baccalauréat vous
savez je ne me suis pas réveillé et dit  je veux
être un junkie je veux être sans abri
j'avais environ 15 ans
et
ma maison a pris feu j'ai fini par
perdre mes deux petites sœurs
un adolescent assez normal
de perdre tout ma famille
tout ce que je savais et
j'étais techniquement sans abri je n'avais
nulle part où vivre
la plupart des toxicomanes que j'ai eu des
expériences avec l'itinérance pendant
ce
traumatisme l'itinérance et la toxicomanie
vont tous de pair et il est rare
de trouver l'un sans l'autre parce que
la toxicomanie et l'itinérance sont un
effet
du traumatisme mais ensuite du traumatisme  est aussi un
effet de l'itinérance et de la
toxicomanie, donc c'est juste un cycle sans fin
et
il est vraiment difficile de briser ce cycle,
il est vraiment difficile d'en sortir et
c'est ce que j'essaie de faire vraiment dur en
ce moment même si je  J'ai encore un
certain type d'instabilité dans le logement Je suis
dans un refuge maintenant
je sais que devenir sobre et essayer de
remettre ma vie sur les rails et de
sortir de l'itinérance, puis finalement
je pourrai guérir ce drame et
tout quitter  cela dans le passé et briser
ce cycle et peut-être vivre comme une
vie normale c'est mon objectif en ce moment c'est
ce que j'espère que
ma mère m'a viré je vivais à new york
je m'écrasais chez mon ami mais
finalement j'étais comme toi  je sais que ce n'est pas
comme pour moi, alors
j'ai économisé un peu d'argent et
j'ai pu aimer louer une chambre, mais c'est
juste génial de faire savoir aux gens que,
circonstanciellement parlant, il y a beaucoup
de façons différentes qui pourraient conduire à l'
itinérance.  ça veut dire nécessairement
faire ça
donc mes potes
ce n'est pas aussi simple que de trouver un travail et d'
obtenir un appartement
si c'était la crise des sans-abris serait
résolue en Amérique
maintenant c'est la dernière fois que je vais faire
une vidéo répondant à ce commentaire parce que
je comprends  non-stop toute la journée
vous avez besoin d'un abri pour trouver un emploi vous ne pouvez pas
trouver d'emploi à moins d'avoir un endroit où
vivre comme une douche vêtements tous ceux dont
ils ont besoin pour travailler la plupart des emplois
alors évidemment en ce moment je suis en
train de  trouver un emploi et je
postule tous les jours, alors j'espère que je
travaillerai bientôt,
alors n'avez-vous pas entendu parler de la
crise du logement la crise qui sévit en Amérique en
ce moment, essentiellement un groupe de gars
disant qu'ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi
je ne peux pas  juste aller emménager avec un mec ou
pourquoi je ne peux pas simplement aller marcher dans la rue
et trouver un mec qui est prêt à subvenir
à mes besoins, c'est comme si c'était la
[ __ ] de chose la plus dangereuse que
j'aie jamais entendue, elle est mariée à
toutes les réunions  pour hra entrer dans
un refuge sont au téléphone si vous êtes
au téléphone vous  Je ne peux pas rester dans un
refuge, des demandes d'emploi et des appels
pour un emploi, comment vais-je en obtenir un
sans téléphone.
Je sais pourquoi vous pensez que juste
parce que je suis sans-abri, je ne suis pas autorisé à
avoir absolument
des biens comme je vais vendre
mon téléphone pour quatre-vingts dollars et acheter une
maison avec
[Musique]
tous les gens qui commentent la haine sur mes
vidéos  ils ne pensent jamais que cela pourrait leur
arriver, soit
utilisez cette application pour trouver des points de vente,
nous allons aller à celui-ci en ce moment,
il y a aussi une salle de bain,
donc c'était une bonne,
ils essaient de faire croire que nous avons fait
quelque chose de mal ou  nous méritons d'être
sans-abri parce que s'ils pensent de cette façon,
ils pensent que cela ne peut pas leur arriver
parce qu'ils ne le méritent pas et c'est
leur façon de se sentir en sécurité
[Musique]
ces dernières années, j'ai définitivement
lutté avec les opiacés  plus que
tout  Sinon
j'étais vraiment dans les benzos j'étais vraiment
dans le xanax klonopin tout ça et ça a
finalement évolué vers l'héroïne et le
fentanyl et tout ça
et maintenant que je suis sobre c'est pourquoi je suis
sous méthadone c'est surtout pour les opiacés
ouais  devoir appeler n'importe qui la
méthadone
fonctionne contre les envies et les
symptômes de la maladie et les sevrage et
tout c'est pourquoi c'est vraiment
bénéfique c'est vraiment difficile de rester
sobre c'est déjà assez difficile de rester sobre en
début de rétablissement quoi
qu'il
arrive donc je lutte avec l'instabilité du logement le
rend  encore plus difficile, je veux
passer ces premiers mois et me sentir de
nouveau sur mes pieds, vous savez, travailler
un travail, avoir une routine, être plus en sécurité dans le
logement, puis je me sentirai plus prêt à
réduire la méthadone et à revenir
à la vie plus normale en
ce moment, je pense que je ne suis pas encore prêt
mais c'est ma nouvelle bouteille
et elle est remplie de jus d'orange égoïste
l'ancienne méthadone était orange mais
les nouvelles que nous recevons sont blanches et
ils le remplissent juste de jus d'orange donc
ça a meilleur goût
ramène généralement un héros au refuge
non je le prends demain d'accord alors j'ai juste
bu le mien pour le jour où tu dois le
faire devant eux
et ensuite ils te donnent ça pour demain
et oui, si vous le vendez ou le buvez, vous
n'avez rien pour le lendemain,
c'est pourquoi la plupart des gens choisissent de le garder,
car sinon vous pouvez tomber malade, je
choisis de garder le mien,
alors nous avons juste reçu l'appel téléphonique et
nous avons été approuvés  pour un logement à long terme,
eh bien, un refuge à long terme, ce n'est pas
un logement réel,
et je suis nerveux parce que nous allons dans une
communauté
complètement différente, une région complètement différente, je n'ai aucune idée de
ce que ça va être, alors
tout le monde espère que c'est  bien pour moi
tout le monde priez pour moi ça va aller
je suis super nerveux je suis super excité et
je suis un peu triste en même temps j'ai
juste beaucoup de sentiments mitigés mais je suis
vraiment reconnaissant que  nous avons été approuvés et
j'étais vraiment excité de le dire à tout le monde alors
t  voici de bonnes nouvelles
hey brad ils veulent une histoire sur la façon dont
nous nous sommes rencontrés il y a environ deux ans et demi je
suis allé en cure de désintoxication pour ma dépendance
et je l'ai rencontré là-bas
nous étions
littéralement obsédés les uns par les autres après
le premier jour où nous nous sommes rencontrés comme tout le monde
plaisanté comme oh romance de réadaptation nous
avons une romance comme ne pas entrer dans une
relation si tôt dans la récupération mais
nous étions obsédés l'un par l'autre depuis
la seconde où nous nous sommes rencontrés
[Musique]
nous avons fini par nous faire expulser
du programme littéralement juste avant moi
terminé c'était un programme de 28 jours j'ai été
expulsé vers le jour 25 ou 2026 pour avoir
poussé son nombril
sans fraterniser du tout c'était autorisé
c'est franc
[Musique]
il a été là pour moi à travers
tout comme j'ai eu des
moments difficiles dans le passé  deux ans et il a
été mon principal système de soutien,
il voulait que je devienne propre, il me dit
quel potentiel j'ai, il m'aide
beaucoup à travers tout et
j'ai une personne qui est toujours là pour
moi, peu importe ce que je
vais  dur et je sais qu'il ne me jugera pas
et c'est drôle parce que
deux ans et demi plus tard et tout le monde
était comme oh romance de réadaptation et nous sommes
mariés et vivons ensemble et ne nous sommes pas
quittés depuis alors peut-
être que nous avons peut-être eu  quelque chose là je
ne sais pas je suis prêt à annoncer ma grande
nouvelle
j'ai un gros entretien à venir pour un
travail que je veux vraiment vraiment euh c'est la
semaine prochaine c'est quelque chose dans mon domaine
quelque chose qui me passionne
donc je  J'apprécierais si tout le monde pouvait
me souhaiter bonne chance pour ça d'accord, je pense que l'
interview eh bien, je ne suis pas douée pour
lire les situations sociales, mais elle a
noté mon numéro de téléphone et a
noté toutes mes réponses à mes questions et
tout, puis m'a dit  qu'il
y aura quelqu'un qui me rappellera
qui fera un deuxième entretien, alors faites
attention à mon téléphone et
vérifiez que mon numéro était correct, c'est donc un
bon signe je pense que c'est un bon signe je
ne sais pas vous les gars dites-moi  si c'est
bon signe, elle semblait r  vraiment comme moi
comme si nous avions eu une bonne
conversation je ne sais pas si je parle trop
parce que je veux vraiment qu'ils m'embauchent tellement
parce que comme si je devais
obtenir un emploi salarié je voulais être
là
juste comme
expliquer comment  utiliser du narcan et donner
des enfants et
donner de la nourriture aux sans-abri
[Musique]
as-tu fait le riz
oh ça a l'air si bon merci
je mange si vite parce que c'est si bon
la seule autre chose que nous avons mangé aujourd'hui était
quand nous avons eu le  Un rouleau de noix de pécan à 75 centimes
de la bodega pour le petit déjeuner et le café
je vous ai dit que c'était tellement bon c'est pourquoi je
me pelletais au visage nous n'avons toujours pas de
cuisinière ou de réfrigérateur au nouvel
abri donc vous ne pouvez pas vraiment vous cuisiner
je sais comme un bon repas fait maison donc
encore à ce jour comme quand nous venons ici
c'est la seule fois où nous obtenons un vrai
bon repas mais leur nourriture est si bonne
je leur ai juste parlé ce matin et
j'ai une deuxième interview c'est bon  nouvelles
je suis juste nerveux
je dois trouver une bonne tenue à porter
parce que je n'ai pas  J'ai beaucoup aimé
les vêtements professionnels,
j'ai traversé beaucoup de choses dans ma vie dont les
autres seraient choqués d'entendre
parler et je n'aime même pas en
parler parce que j'ai aussi l'impression que les
sans-abri ne devraient pas avoir
ce sanglot  histoire pour vous faire sentir
qu'ils méritent un logement nous sommes tous des
êtres humains et nous avons tous traversé et nous
méritons toujours des choses comme les droits fondamentaux
et le logement et le respect et la nourriture et
la chance de vivre une vie normale
quand nous nous promenions ici  et
j'avais comme toutes mes couvertures et nous avions
évidemment l'air sales comme si mes cheveux n'étaient
pas coiffés et j'étais juste comme un grand
t-shirt et tout le monde
nous regardait comme maintenant comme si nous marchions à travers vous
savez que personne ne vous regarde et c'est juste
bizarre parce que comme je suis toujours sans abri, je
viens de mieux nettoyer c'est tout
[Musique]
mes journées sont définitivement encore difficiles,
je suis toujours inquiet de ne
pas être embauché ou de ne pas trouver de travail
et je  ne vais pas être en mesure d'obtenir tout
type de revenu
le  il y a tellement de choses qui pourraient arriver
demain je pourrais me réveiller et ils pourraient
dire hé tu ne peux plus être au refuge
tu es de retour dans la rue
[Musique]
je ne contrôle pas très bien ma vie en ce
moment et c'est  effrayant mais je sais que c'est
quelque chose que je dois traverser si je
veux finalement m'en sortir alors
j'espère juste le meilleur
[Musique]
handicap